alors jacques tu as eu une enfance elle
à la dickens un peu un peu ton père
avait fait la guerre de 14 il était
parti à 20 ans carrière va faire la
grande guerre oui il en était devenu
complètement excentré et
du 23 ou par un peu un peu c'est un
euphémisme et buvette où le temps du
whisky nancy lui tomber dessus
une fois il paraît qu'il a vu de l'autre
colonne aïe aïe ça doit être pour ça que
j'ai les cheveux bouclés
il en est mort oui il en est mort mais
il a pris son temps c'est adam parr toi
tu t'es retrouvé au collège au collet
était celui qu'on n'est pas voir très
souvent pas trop non mais gt gt dans un
collège dans un collège catholique et
j'ai reçu une éducation très dur qui m'a
fait trouvé après la vie mérite d'être
en vacances avec mes années de pensions
c'était mal vu parce que ta mère pays en
retard oui un petit peu mais tu dont tu
sais tout je sais tout et dans cet art
c'était c'était une enfance assez morose
il désirait pas voir du chocolat mais il
a lu ma vie là le plus jeune a pas
encore écrite tv
non non on dirait que tu as des
feuillants entre les mains oui c'est
assez banal tout ça mais c'est ce qui
conduit au théâtre et là j'ai vraiment
trouvé une famille et depuis je n'ai
jamais trahi ce qu'en dit la faire le
pitre collège voilà pour finir etr à la
télévision finalement tu trouves cette
éducation pas mauvaise tué parce que tu
dis aujourd'hui qu'il faut avoir une
éducation à ces directives pour ses
enfants
je pense que c'est très important que
l'éducation soit une épreuve dont on
triomphe aujourd'hui à six enfants
6 mais j'ai pas fini n'a pas fini tu dis
qu'ils ont ce qu'ils trouvent tous super
génial et cta un peu déçu de son laxisme
moi j'aime mieux que mes enfants me
trouve sympa que mais c'était pas un
service à l'art on est trop sympa avec
eux je pense qu'être père c'est être
père
jusqu'au mois mes enfants peuvent
compter sur moi jusque dans les pires
moments
je suis leur père donc je suis deux
partis pris c'est eux que j'aime d'abord
je suis là chemin de parti pris pour mes
enfants
vite la première erreur c'est pas avoir
jeté la bouteille de ketchup le premier
jour à tout ça aussi avant j'étais vexé
parce que j'aime la cuisine c'est dans
la famille cellule dans le son père
était cuisinier du dard et mon grand
père était chef de cuisine du dark est
aussi je vais peut-être touché
maintenant que le dollar risque de
revenir grâce à vous tu risques
thierry ce que touche et peut-être
l'empereur russe tu sécurisé le
rembourser mais je sais toutes les
familles françaises en ont plein dans
leur armoire est souple alors grenier
dont je ne pense pas pour touche
l'emprunt russe sais quoi mais pour
revenir aux enfants je pense qu'il ya un
seul truc est important quand on est des
enfants c'est l'exemplarité
quand tu les vois regard des dessins
animés japonais ou ou manger du ketchup
intérieur à ses pastèques sais pas mais
je sais par tulio texte avait mis des
petits mots dans les livres rares ou
inédits de vendée pas cette édition pour
acheter à vélo seul vrai à l'époque
et puis finalement ils n'ont pas touché
non je les en remercie est ce qu'ils
montrent des enfants bien sûr à mon bien
les enfants aussi bien que moi un pur
récemment très très bien oui tu vas voir
cela